امل في مفاوضات جده بين طرفي الصراع في
السودان القوه السياسيه والمدنيه
السودانيه ترحب بالمبادره السعوديه
الامريكيه بدايه من قوى الحريه والتغيير
التي اكدت ان المفاوضات يجب ان تكون
بنوايا صادقه وجاده من اجل انجاحها والدعم
السريع اشاد بالجهود الاقليميه والدوليه
للوصول الى وقف اطلاق نار يسهل فتح ممرات
انسانيه والجبهه الثوريه في السودان قالت
ان جهود الدولتين في المفاوضات مقدمه
ضروريه لفتح باب الحوار
اما جيش تحرير السودان فقد قال انه يجب
عدم ربط الحلول بالاتفاق الايطالي الذي
اصبح سببا مباشرا للحرب اما المتحدث باسم
العمليه السياسيه في السودان اعرب عن امله
في ان تتوصل المباحثات الى وقف كامل
لاطلاق النار يمهد لحل سياسي شامل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات